alyssa is with us in oklahoma city hi
alyssa how are you
i'm good hi guys i have a quick question
um my husband and i just finished baby
step two
march 20th and we are on baby step three
but we are having a military move coming
up
um in july so we're kind of putting that
on pause for now but
my question my husband recently came to
me with an idea of his
is to sell his truck that we just paid
off
um and downgrade quote unquote
um to a uh about a ten thousand dollar
less vehicle and i don't i want to make
the right decision and that's
kind of that's where i'm
when he says gas mileage and it just
it's not a truck because you have a
truck and so he wanted to downgrade to
an suv um what kind of truck you know
why you know this is where i'm kind of
worried
suv is not from a truck is not a gas
mileage move
yeah yeah uh yeah so from a it's a 2018
silverado and he was looking at a rav4
toyota so i don't know that probably
would change gas mileage yeah
yeah now that just how much does he
drive
um we right now we live we he's a drill
sergeant so we're very close to where he
works
um but when we move it'll be maybe a 30
minute
drive um one way um
i was not sure is he trying to use this
extra money to put inside of baby step
three
is that what he's trying to do yeah if
we pocketed the 10
000 difference and from my understanding
um it would go to our fully funded
america we'd be done with baby step 3.
so and so you're like dave you must
really like the truck huh
uh it's my husband not me but
i think he he really liked the truck and
now i'm kind of
thinking it's a monkey wrench because we
just paid it off and kept with it
and now he's talking about downgrading i
don't know if he says it's because he's
seeing the big picture
and i just i don't want to just make a
decision very quickly
and i don't know if it's silly to
downgrade or
just keep it i don't know if it's silly
to keep a truck as well when he says
he's seen the big picture
what is he gaining by selling the truck
ten thousand dollars in the baby step
three
that's the big picture move that's what
he's wanting to accomplish
pretty much he values that more than he
does this truck over a rev4
i'm not sure well that must be why he's
wanting to do this unless there's some
other reason he wants to do it
yeah i think he just wants a downgrade
is what i'm saying
i know but there's nobody vaguely wants
to downgrade i mean there's a reason
absolutely especially once y'all just
paid it off well how much do y'all
vaguely want to upgrade i don't vaguely
want to downgrade
elisa how much do you make so much of a
downgrade yeah
take home uh is around 47
a year
yeah you need to downgrade yeah he's
been actually listening to what we teach
you have you have a truck you have a
truck that's too expensive
yeah that's what he's seeing yeah you've
got too much tied up and things going
down in value
okay i'm assuming that that's what's
happening is that he's a little more
plugged into what we're talking about in
teaching than maybe you are
because we tell people not to have more
than half of their income tied up in
vehicles and you probably do